how come the left doesn't complain about
handy or Laura Ingram
and they he said it's because Tucker's
the only one who was anti-war and
anti-big Pharma yeah so the left went
after him and completely ignores the
safe GOP
and that's what Fox News wants to be
they don't want Tucker Carlson coming
out here and saying these things yeah
they want someone to go on and just be
like big corporations are great
everybody just do what the government
says exactly they would love that a
Tucker one honors like the left wants
you to think that these corporations
drink bad things to America they're our
best friends actually they do great
things
um but I sort of mentioned this
yesterday that CNN is the network that
tells you what you're supposed to
believe and then Fox is the network that
tells you what you're allowed to believe
so if you don't want to buy into what
CNN is saying they'll push you over to
Fox and that's still within the realm of
acceptable opinion but Tucker's a little
Bridge Too Far yeah he's a bridge a
little too far it's too far man yeah
yeah then he actually says something you
know cable news commentators they're all
buzzwords